Jennifer blow my is one of about 45,000
students in Dortmund the city has both a
university and a Technical College of
Applied Science and Arts now on the
campus where I've spent lots of time
over the past three years we have lots
of cool young people here and Dortmund
is a really cool City right now it's her
semester break
but Jenny still goes to the campus
because the deadline to hand in her
bachelor's degree dissertation is coming
up although she comes from the Ruhr
region Dortmund was a surprise to her at
first I'd never have thought that
Dortmund was such a young hip city but
it's changed so I'm going to show you my
three favorite places recommendation
number one is high month design the shop
has been here for six years it's on
horror Vaude part of the street that
encircles the city centered
hi my design of that design is my
favorite shop in Dortmund it's a concept
store where you can buy both clothing
and furniture and it gives young
designers a chance to see how that
product seldom acts
in addition to its shop high mop design
also hosts trade fairs and lectures and
it has a showroom where young designers
can present their ideas it even has its
own magazine it's published every six
months and it's free of charge then it's
on to her second recommendation isn't it
but now at my next hit the courts
festival
that's quite severe here I think the
coins fertile is the loveliest district
in Atlanta there are lots of cafes shops
bars and restaurants where you can eat
well in the evening drink and just make
friends the district is in the western
part of the city and it's especially
attractive to students and young
families Jenny really likes to go to the
keatster gym that's a cafe where they
bake their own cakes using local organic
ingredients you come on here you can get
really good tea coffee and cakes it's
nice and quiet which I like there are
lots of small cafes like this you can
really relax here her last tip is the
Dortmunder you Arts Center the
Dortmunder Union brewery is a landmark
in the city and it's also a popular
place to meet
all come on this is a great place to
party or see exhibitions like some I've
helped arrange but I really want to show
you the observation platform on top it's
great for taking pictures great
throughout the whole city back there is
the railway station and there's the
center of Dortmund and shopping precinct
and the best thing is that you get a 360
degree view of Dortmund free of charge
and those were Jennifer bloomers
recommendations for a great visit to
Dortmund